التغيير يلوح في الأفق ولكن هنا في فولادا
روسيا هي نفسها،
ومن غير الواضح ما إذا كانت
هذه المدينة الصغيرة هي نقطة انطلاق للهجوم
المضاد لأوكرانيا ولكن موسكو
تقصفها فقط للتأكد من وجود
قصة مماثلة هنا أيضًا على  ضفة النهر
بالقرب من منطقة الشعر، حيث يقال إن
القوات الأوكرانية ربما تعبر إلى
المناطق المحتلة، ويزعم المسؤولون أنهم يستشهدون
بنتائج مثيرة للإعجاب يوم الثلاثاء، حيث
ضربت غارة جوية روسية على الرغم من أنه من غير الواضح
ما الذي أصابها،
إلا أن أوكرانيا ظلت صامتة بشأن
هجومها الكبير على الرغم من بعض
مقاطع الفيديو الغامضة على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التي تشير إلى الحركة.
وفقًا
لمسؤول أوكراني من بلدة
ماليتا بول، فإن القوات الروسية تتحرك بالتأكيد، لذا نرى
الآن أنهم انتقلوا بحيث
يشكلون أساسًا كبيرًا للقوات الروسية،
وتقع كل هذه القاعدة على
شاطئ البحر في إلسي أكثر من  على بعد 100
كيلومتر من خط المواجهة قال مازحًا
عن مدى شيوع الحوادث بالنسبة
للروس، أحدهم ينقلب على قاذفة
الصواريخ هذه خاصة على خط السكة الحديد الحيوي
للإمدادات العسكرية ربما ثلاثة أسابيع
لا توجد كهرباء على السكة الحديد
ويستخدمون قطارات ديزل قديمة وقبل بضعة
أيام أه  حدث شيء ما في
قطارات الديزل
وكان حريقًا كبيرًا والآن لا يوجد
أه هذا الديزل عندما تقول حدث شيء ما،
فأنت تعني أنه كان هناك انفجار
وأنت تعرف شيئًا عن ذلك،
حدث شيء ما
تحدثنا إلى رجل محلي فر من
المدينة لمدة أربعة أيام  قبل
عدم وجود القوات الروسية المناسبة، كان
المجندون حديثًا فقط هم من
لن يقاتلوا إذا لم يتم تهديدهم
بإطلاق النار عليهم بسبب سوء الانضباط،
كل شخص محلي يشتبه في أي شخص آخر
بشيء، حتى الأشخاص الذين يشربون
الفودكا معك لا يمكنهم التحدث  حتى الآن
لا تزال موسكو تواصل ما تسميه
عمليات الإجلاء، وهذه حلقة أخرى من
الأطفال الأوكرانيين الذين يتم إرسالهم إلى ما
تسميه روسيا الأمان
هنا 43 من منطقة تقع مباشرة في طريق
الهجوم المضاد المتجه إلى
بيلاروسيا حليفة موسكو
لقضاء عطلة لمدة أسبوعين  وقد عُرض على آخرين في الماضي
رحلة مماثلة ولكن تم احتجازهم لعدة أشهر.
وقالت أوكرانيا إنه تم ترحيل 20 ألف شخص
بالفعل، وقد أدى ذلك إلى توجيه
لائحة اتهام بارتكاب جرائم حرب ضد الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين،
ومن غير الواضح ما الذي سيحدث بعد ذلك بالنسبة لهم
وللبلدة التي تقع في مرمى مغادرتهم.
خلف